hey guys this is short update today I
got a few things that I want to cover
number one the live stream is still on
August 23rd that is a Saturday I believe
two weeks from now and wait is
definitely going to be there as well as
a possibility of a Bob arriving during
the live stream we're still finalizing a
few things to make sure that he can get
in and out back in time to go back to
his lawyer in duty at school or whatever
he's doing but also there's going to be
a very special giveaway and I made sure
that I doing all the right things that I
can be able to do this I'm going to be
giving away 15 Apple iPods the new 16
gigabyte version and they are the red
version so a part of the profit from me
buying them goes towards AIDS research
so it's kind of a double thing for
charity all you need to do is literally
show up you don't need to have anything
else you don't need to buy anything you
don't even need to donate you don't need
the order shirt you don't need to do
nothing so just make sure that you're in
the stream and that your name is in the
chat because that's how I'm going to be
picking people and we're going to be
giving away like a few every hour so to
make sure that it's fair random and
everyone has an equal chance now
obviously this isn't a lot compared to
how many people are going to be in there
but I wanted to be able to do something
special for you guys to reward those who
weren't able to donate and we're just in
the stream itself also I did a collab
with Jack's film just recently it's over
on his channel there it is right there
it's going away real quick click and
click I like it okay it's gone so you'll
never ever ever be able to see it again
except through the link in the
description below there may be a toss up
on what is for sale this live stream
it's even going to be the pajama pants
or the tiny box Tim plushie now I know
that both of these are going to be
popular items and I know that probably
the plushie people are dying for but
there's a bit of a slowness thing
happening with getting the things made
and shipped over to wherever they're
coming from I don't know maker studios
is handling all that they just send me
emails every once in a while though
whichever one gets in first is going to
be the thing that is available on the
live stream to buy to go towards charity
whatever that is whatever it may be
that's what it's gonna be but two great
choices either way I'll let you know the
closer we get to it I still don't know
what charity specifically we're gonna be
doing it for but it's going to be a good
one
and I hope you guys are more than
willing to support its costs so thank
you guys in advance for participating
and I hope you win something oh so I
these windows don't do anything it's
literally boiling you I I'm really
sweaty right now other than that I
really don't have anything new to talk
about oh wait yes I do of course I do
I'm going to PAX Prime I don't know how
I didn't mention that before I am going
to PAX Prime there was a bit of a mix-up
with the media badges that I didn't know
exactly if I was gonna be able to get a
badge but now I definitely do and I may
even have a panel when I'm there it's
not a hundred percent but I may have a
panel with me and Wade bobs
unfortunately not going to pax but way
it is so me and Wade may have our own
panel at PAX where you can ask us
questions and participate in audience
fundis whatever the hell we decide to do
with you guys when you get there won't
be anything bad I promise or that bad it
will be so anyway I hope to meet a bunch
of people I mean after comic-con and
meeting so many you guys I can't wait to
get in side there and with you guys in
the happy fundis that we're gonna have I
mean pax is the first convention that I
really went to where I was dedicated
just me you know comic-con I've been
going to with my brother but pax was the
first one that I went to on my own so I
can't wait to be in there in the gaming
central and see all the exhibits and
hopefully try out some of the new stuff
that's coming for next year so just
thank you guys so much for your constant
support and you know I say it over and
over again but I really do appreciate
what you guys do for me and some people
have asked why I've suddenly started
telling people you know that I believe
in them or that I want them to do great
things and it's not sudden you know I've
been doing this since the entire time
I've been doing YouTube I really just
want to emphasize how much you guys have
influenced me and
you pushed me to do great things and the
least that I can do is try to tell you
how awesome you already are
you know I'm me telling you isn't making
you any better you are already good
people at heart and if I can try to push
you you know just a few more steps
further to be able to reach your goals
and you know it's really the least I can
do because you guys are amazing
everything that you've done up to this
point you know it's it's your life
people may try to bring you down people
will always try to bring you down you
know there's always going to be people
that will say that you're not good
enough or that you should be doing it
some other way or you should just forget
your dreams because they're unrealistic
but dreams are supposed to be
unrealistic you're supposed to be able
to reach for the stars you're supposed
to be able to reach as high as you can
and put yourself as far as you can go
because you never know what your limits
are until you reach them so that's what
I'm trying to get at I want you guys to
be able to reach your full potential
because you never know what you can do I
never thought I'd be able to do YouTube
I never thought I'd be anywhere near the
level of success that I am and it's all
because of you guys but I'm just one guy
no I'm just one that's why I emphasize
the power of one like one subscriber one
person out there is so important you
know I may be getting close to three
million and that's great I'm so grateful
that you guys are supporting me but in
reality I still try to make sure that I
understand that one subscriber one
subscriber more and one person more is
another person on another side of a
computer that believes not just as oh
they like my videos but I want them to
know me as a person because they're not
just number on the other side of the
screen they're an actual person they
have dreams and hopes I always try to
remember that and I want you guys from
every single person in this community
has a backstory and the family life
tragic hopes
they all matter every single one of you
matter so I don't want you to have a
freaking anyway I said this is gonna be
a short video and I ended up yammering
on for hours and hours because that's
what I want to do most of the time I'm
talking myself alone in my apartment
just thank you guys so much for your
constant support and your love and
outpouring of affection
it means the world so anyway August 23rd
is when the lachen is wait is definitely
gonna be there Bob might be there
hopefully yes maybe definitely and we're
giving away Apple iPods I don't think I
mentioned they're also engraved on the
back they say mark pliers he rose on
them each and every one of them so hope
you guys win wish I could give one to
everyone Jack's film Barrett is gonna
outkick on thank you again everybody
you're awesome hope to see you at PAX
and thank you for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
you